l'ukraine au coeur des tensions
géopolitiques entre la russie l'otan et
les états unis place à notre décryptage
avec nos invités pour en parler avec
nous claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales karim b
checcolo fco professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou bonsoir à
tous les deux merci d'être là pour ce
décryptage sur la situation en ukraine
et ses conséquences afin de vous faire
réagir je voudrais vous faire écouter le
commentaire de jens stoltenberg
secrétaire général de l'otan lors de la
réunion de la commission otan ukraine
c'était aujourd'hui à bruxelles
nous discuterons également des actions
agressives de la russie en ukraine
nous sommes tous préoccupés par ce
renforcement terre massif à la frontière
et la russie doit y mettre fin
elle doit cesser les provocations et
procéder à une désescalade détention
karina bisch ecoval go une réaction à
ces propos à sept points de vue de
bergues et que j'ai pas été connectées
donc j'ai pas pu entendre ce qui s'est
passé en substance le secrétaire général
de l'otan qui dit voilà on est préoccupé
par ce renforcement militaire massif à
la frontière avec la russie qui doit
cesser ses provocations et procéder à
une désescalade immédiate
bonjour donc effectivement ou peut être
un peu surpris de ce genre de propos
puisque ces derniers temps les les
américains renforcent leur présence
militaire sous couvert de l'otan dans
leur nuque rennes et rappelons quand
même que les troupes russes
elle se trouve sur le territoire de la
russie donc si di scala il doit y avoir
peut-être faut-il demander aussi un
retrait au thd des troupes étrangères
qui se passe sur place certes il y a
actuellement des des exercices
militaires qui sont prévus ni ce n'est
pas une faisons nous pour provoquer un
site et puisque comme l'a souligné
d'ailleurs là aussi ils ont les
informations selon lesquelles l'otan a
su v12 d'activités de soutien et de
formation à la et genyen met en place
des bases pour lancer derrière des
coupes qui peuvent lancer des attaques
terroristes notamment en russie n'est
pas uni ont également s'inquiéter pour
de petites la turquie dans tout ce
processus
effectivement il ya un problème si vous
voulez très très sérieux puisque c'est
une zone extrêmement sensible et
lorsqu'il y à un conflit territorial
avec une dominante militaire comme c'est
le cas en ukraine avec le don d'as il
est quand même surprenant de voir des
exercices de l'otan se passer sur cette
victoire
en tout cas c'est ce que moscou qui
dénonce indépendant massif de troupes à
la frontière comme l'indiquent le
ministre russe de la défense que l'on
écoute 1 en réaction aux activités
militaires renaissance de l'alliance
atlantique nous avons pris les mesures
appropriées en trois semaines deux
armées trois divisions de troupes
aéroportées ont pu être transférés vers
les frontières occidentale de la russie
pour participer à des camps dans une
maison c'est un petit peu compliqué
lorsqu'un diplomate que vous êtes en
tout le monde se renvoie un peu la balle
dans cette affaire alors c'est vrai que
la russie fait que tu des exercices
militaires comme nous l'a dit karine
béchère goal of qu'auprès des frontière
ukrainienne mais l'otan et les états
unis pourtant loin de chez eux se
rapprochent dangereusement de la
frontière de la russie c'est une
différence qu'il faut relever tout de
même je crois que depuis depuis sept ans
il ya eu beaucoup de périodes de crise
d'antan fait dans cette région et il ya
d'ailleurs eu treize mille morts
finalement au cours de ces conflits le
cessez-le-feu de du mois de juillet
dernier est assez mal respecté puisqu'il
ya encore quelques morts des deux côtés
la ligne de cessez le feu en ukraine et
aujourd'hui on a en effet à une
situation extrêmement sérieuse avec un
regain de tension certains voudraient
décrire la situation actuelle comme le
remake du scénario de l'ossétie du sud
ans en 2018 en 2008 par dont ceux ci n'a
évidemment rien à voir
la situation est complètement différente
puisque aujourd'hui en réalité l'ukraine
n'a pas du tout l'intention de résoudre
le problème du non basse par les moyens
militaires son gouvernement l'a toujours
répété ce problème doit être résolu par
des moyens politiques
alors évidemment on peut toujours dire
que monsieur hélène ce qu'ils cherchent
à prendre son avantage d'autant plus qu'
une nouvelle administration américaine
depuis le 20 janvier et qu'il cherche à
vérifier
de ce côté s'il est possible de gagner
une aide militaire supplémentaire ou sur
le plan politique de se rapprocher de
l'otan mais encore une fois la situation
est complètement différente de celle que
l'on a connue pour la géorgie en 2008
notamment parce que si il y avait un
problème important
comme le dit dimitri kozak hier je crois
c'est responsable de l'oesa fer
ukrainienne au kremlin eh bien monsieur
kozak a dit bien sûr s'il est l'avis des
russophones du dombass dont certains ont
des passeports russes d'ailleurs été
menacé la russie interviendrait mais ça
n'est pas le cas parce qu'ils ne sont
pas menacés et s'il n'était et bien
évidemment dans la circonstances
actuelles il est probable que une
intervention russe susciterait cette
fois ci une intervention américaine ne
serait ce que parce que tout le monde
regarde les américains y compris les
chinois l'ukraine en tout cas appelle
les
occidentaux a accéléré son adhésion à
l'otan pour envoyer un message clair à
la russie
comment est perçue cette réunion côté
russe karine béchec holosko justement
cette réunion remet largement en cause
le discours qui effectivement est menée
mais c'est un discours selon lequel
l'ukraine veut une résolution politique
et non militaire du profit tout d'abord
il faudrait savoir ce que l'ukraine est
capable de vouloir et dans quelle mesure
à la les moyens de ce qu'elle veut pour
l'instant on peut quand même
sérieusement douter de l'autonomie et de
l'indépendance de l'ukraine a décidé
tant de sa politique intérieure que de
sa politique extérieure puisque comme
nous le voyons chaque réforme intérieure
est dictée par un des organes
internationaux et ce qui conditionne
l'octroi d'un certain nombre de prêts
donc disons que la volonté étatique de
l'ukraine laisse quand même beaucoup pas
désiré en ce qui concerne l'entrée dans
l'otan c'est un un pas qui souligne une
volonté de confrontation puisque l'otan
n'est quand même pas une oeuvre
caritative
c'est une organisation militaire et
c'est une organisation qui est déjà
extrêmement présente sur le sol
ukrainien
c'est une organisation qui a développe
les capacités de l'armée ukrainienne
donc on peut tout à fait considérer qu
effectivement tout état doit d'avoir son
armée claude marche maison vous partager
également cette analyse en tout cas
cette intégration de l otan ça serait la
ligne rouge évidemment pour moscou on
imagine oui bien sûr mais je pense que
monsieur et 20 ce qui encore une fois
joue sa partition mais que pas plus que
la géorgie
e l'ukraine ne rentrera dans l'otan dans
un avenir proche
d'abord parce que dans le passé deux
pays européens la france est là et
l'allemagne s'y sont opposés en faisant
valoir que c'était un peu cédé trop
agressif vis-à-vis de la russie et
ensuite parce que ce pays est un pays
divisé et que je ne vois pas bien un
pays divisé devenir un pays membre de
l'otan
par conséquent bien sûr il ya une
coopération comme le dit le professeur
cette coopération est importante mais je
ne vois pas dans un avenir proche les
l'ukraine rejoindre rejoindre l'otan est
en réalité ce qui se passe c'est que
chacun essaie de tester la dea le degré
de détermination de la nouvelle
administration biden après tout monsieur
bayonne avait été qualifié par monsieur
choï de sleepy jo et ils montrent qu'il
n'est pas stupide jo qui n'est pas clean
jo il prend des décisions et
effectivement il est un peu obligé de
les faire respecter
donc là chacun se regarde en chiens de
faïence et je ne pense pas que la férule
chrétienne dégénère en conflit
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
clauses blanche maison merci également à
15,9 échec au boycot koloko pardon
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france pour ce décryptage